let's give us a shot going to pick up
over here the question says what is this
is Part B or rather show that the speed
of the car as it passes the truck is and
then there's your expression down the
bottom so you can you see what I've done
it's just a substitution you just got to
know where you're substituting the
answer it's about the velocity of the
car at a known time and with an
acceleration so I'm kind of doing two
substitution at ones ok so I'll pause my
a in right there [ __ ] the key in and
then everything just kind of comes out
in the wash nice and easy ok now here
comes the interesting part we need to
use that equation down there there's bit
and we need to use it to answer Part C
now look at it for a second with me the
objective of the driver of the car is to
spend as little time alongside the truck
as possible what strategies could the
driver employed hmm ok so let's think
about this for a second right remember
what's going on we want to overtake we
do it fast ok so if you're trying to
cover a large distance like over taking
the truck in a small amount of time what
is the first most obvious strategy that
you should point you want to go as fast
as possible right took the first thing
we assume there's some kind of speed
limit in place so it's like well just
hit the speed limit when you're
overtaking ok now just mark that and
this is actually worth even writing
because it's counterintuitive in terms
of an implication that it has right we
want to hit the speed limit
at the point of overtaking
now this might seem like well obviously
so that it right I want you to have a
look at this equation we've just written
down write the velocity of the car so
make this thing as big as possible have
a look down at all the bits and pieces
that go into this expression let's take
them one by one capital v can we change
capital v no we can't it's cluster right
but not just as a closet like what kind
of constant is it and the answer is well
in this situation who do you think is
defining capital v the truck is to find
a capital V right it has its own maximum
speed in your yard stuff like that
that's the problem okay so it's not just
it's a constant it's a constant you're
not in charge on does that make sense
okay look again what's the next one this
see here what is see this is the
distance between the car on the track
now this is also a constant but unlike v
I can change I can make this whatever I
like does that make sense now one last
concert l was that you
that's how far i am from the oath-taking
live does that make sense so this is
like right now okay what's my option
here okay now again I can't change that
because the truck is where it is so I
have a single point adji that I have
control over a single constant I should
take capital C now if I you told me go
faster go faster so if this whole
expression here if this is the velocity
of the car and this is the only thing I
can affect then do I want this number to
be big or small
the facebook
I want the whole thing to be me right so
therefore being a [ __ ] control this [ __ ]
control this this is on a numerator
right it's not an inverse proportion
it's not an investment variation this is
on the numerator so the bigger this is
the bigger the whole thing is I just
pause for a second where's that mean if
you want to overtake the truck fast are
you should be further away how does that
way think about it think that has work
what do you really want artists all
right okay right so if I'm further back
over here ok I'm going to give you a
slightly different picture now okay I
want you to picture a guy who's going to
have a standing start for a 100-meter
race okay so here here's the race maybe
you okay now you've timed it you're
behind you're behind what you want is to
be able to like you have to both start
running from this position think of that
position as the start of your overtaking
Lane okay aha so what you want is if you
both have to start there you want the
biggest run of you care right so that
instant when they just start going
you're already shooting off like a
bullet does that make sense so any of
you of you sir I used to coach football
right any of you have played cutters
probando when the ball is here right
like someone's just been you know
touched and so it's okay I'm gonna pick
up the ball now the dummy half I'm gonna
pass it to you right the person who's
going to receive they like way back
there cuz they've got to have a massive
run-up does that make sense because like
look this is where I have to start so
therefore I might it will start from
there at the biggest velocity I care and
that comes from making this distance
which is counter-intuitive go fast start
by being further away it's
counterintuitive but that's what the
numbers that's what the expression tells
you does that make sense so got two
things maximize speed within speed
limits number two in order to do that
maximize the distance between you and
the truck okay now i just read into the
final pilot question part a trader with
me there's quite a bit to read the speed
limits hundred k turn our trucks
traveling at 90 kg our and this distance
here this gap is 50 meters okay how far
before the overtaking Lane should the
car begin to accelerate to do what we
wanted so there are some easy business
of hardness the first thing i knows is
that i were to get to the velocity of a
car be 100 km/h but look carefully at
the question has to find V and actually
all of our velocity functions like
anything they're all going to be in
meters per second so you can see here
I've done a pair of conversions right I
had to convert this my current speed
that's capital V and this switch is my
target speed that's the you telling me
go as fast and possibly care that's when
I want to hit it okay so it's going to
be you can see how I did that conversion
right to get from 190 I x 10 online
anyway those are numbers so what I want
is to get the bossy of the car to be
this this is my match right 250 on nine
this is the left-hand side of my
equation that I just did invite me
well that velocity 100 km/h 250 or nine
meters per second what is my current
faucet
90 days in our which is 25 meters per
second okay I've got it one
tell me what's going on in here what
have I got what's known what under
see is the distance between the curler
truck I know that it's a given quantity
that's 100 well it's 50 but you have to
double it is a to c 0 when you read it
yeah you with me and then there's L
right that's how far away the truck is
note the truck how far the truck is from
you're taking late that's the only
Prairie rule I know it that I have so
can you help me solve what would you
like me to do it how about to buy both
sides by 25 which will give me 10 10 or
9 1 plus this guy what would you like me
to do subtract which leaves me with 109
and now I can cross multiply
have I answered the question not at all
because there's words in this question I
need to explain what's going on l of
course is this distance over here do you
love my to scale diagram ok so this
apparently is 900 the cast is sorry the
question says how far before the
overtaking when should the car begin to
accelerate so this is 900 where's the
car it's nine hundred and fifty meters
away from the overtaking room you see
what's going on ok so being that L is
900 that distance therefore car should
begin accelerating
I even put a tiny bit of working here
900 plus that distance 950 meters from
the overtaking me
and well done
you just put yourself in that category
before you can do extension questions in
the deep recession